so last night got a little out of hand  oh just a little out of hand on Twitter  what can we learn from this  I think what we can learn from this is  caring about something that's silly is  Good escapism from focus and  realism I think we all need a little  escapism even if it seemingly looks  unhinged and unhealthy like my New York  Jets rants last night the reality is is  sometimes caring about something that  really in the scheme of things about  like your family's health or big  politics issue like real life sometimes  it's good you know and so  um even when it's ugly like last night  was I do think that every one of us  needs a hobby or something that we care  about that seemingly might seem silly to  others but it helps us balance the  reality of our real life that's what  they are for me